you seem like you've been a very good
job of preserving your normalcy your
sanity your a big story you must get
recognized all the times and how are you
when you're just walking through New
York City or anywhere and people stop
you and want to talk to you are you
uncomfortable in those situations yes I
used to be really uncomfortable and I
would like I would kind of get like
irritable because I felt so strange you
know I felt like I felt I guess like I
was being mocked I don't know why I was
just my go-to feeling I guess at all
times and then my more people shoving
and going no they were saying hi it's
really nice to meet you and I was
hearing haha yeah so I know that really
well that's exactly that's all I do is
respond that way to people I can't help
but this is how I look exactly yes just
apologize immediately and my mother told
me don't be mean to people and so I said
okay and now I'm nice and I like that
she waited that long to give you that
lesson until then I'd be like I know
whatever you all wait maybe you should
yeah they're 22 now it's time to not be
mean to be yeah we didn't know you're
gonna be famous so we always said just
be however you want no but now it's
great because now I can like I used to
like eavesdrop on people's conversations
because I write I always try to like
hear interesting things I can't really
do that anymore because people will
notice me and they will talk to me but
now I can do this other thing where I
can ask invasive personal questions
because they've already approached me so
I still get like the benefit of the
eavesdropping but none of the swell
somebody that's it well like someone
comes up to be like oh wow Jesse
Eisenberg I love your movies so cool to
meet you what are you up to
I don't stare you still married yeah
what's funny I was married but it fell
apart it didn't work out why what
happened well I'm impotent and yeah
so you find out all this great stat I
know that yes yes what's the story
behind that horrible scar could ask that
because the thing is they've already
come up to me so right right the burden
is on them to be you got to get yours
that's right I'll sign this autograph
but show me your prenup
[Laughter]